you bienvenue dans cet épisode de ask
alors parce que c'est toutes les deux ou
trois semaines c'est un format court où
je répondrai à une ou plusieurs
questions que vous voulez vous chers
internautes n'avaient posé et plus d'1
pose depuis un an je crois si ce direct
que ça n'aura aucune incidence sur la
fréquence des postes du coup de fil en
gros c'est comme l'a vécu philo que
j'avais en février dernier sauf que je
réponds 4 une ou deux questions et
l'idée c'est le genre de faire une sorte
de fil rouge autour de ces questions que
je reçois régulièrement et et non de
faire une vidéo de 15 minutes de temps
en temps ce sera des questions du coup
de fil au mais aussi de psycho ça peut
déborder sur je parle du sociétal de la
science
bref voilà pour l'instant bas va pas se
restreindre à ces parties mes amis mes
habitudes des masques à l'ask huit ans
pose plus tard n'a donné aucune question
de roger van tol
visiblement un homme de goût un homme
d'élégance roger dentelle qui nous
demande qu'est ce qui définit le bien et
le mal
et rajoute qu est ce qui fait que le
bien est bien avec le manama or ces deux
notions c'est avant tout des limites
parce qu'on a besoin de se donner des
limites et des repères lorsqu'on décide
de vivre ensemble un peu comme quand tu
décides de te mettre en colocation
ces deux concepts de bien et mal ils
sont ancestraux ils ont été définies
entre autres avec la religion du hilal
et des règles comme par exemple les dix
commandements et en gros les respecter
c'est bien ne pas les respecter c'est
mal
ensuite on remarque que c'est des
notions qui sont entourés de tension
lors par exemple le bien est bonne ou
moneo au bonheur le mal mais nos
malheurs voix et même les grecs ils vont
plus loin en y associant le pot alors
pour les cas qui est un vrai idéal du
beau et du bon c'est ce qui s'appelle
qu'à los gatos le bo était une vertu et
donc fallait travailler cette vertu
comme une autre donc sous fait l'erreur
de dire m filles qu'elle est bonne
n'hésitez pas à faire appel auquel hors
cac atos conseil
c'est vrai que ça marche elle pour
fermer cette parenthèse
voici un graphique du site ok cupid ce
un site de rencontre on a demandé ou non
de noter les autres utilisateurs
suivant leur beauté et leur personnalité
il remarque bas c'est plutôt linéaires
c'est à dire que vente mais généralement
tu as la personnalité citée beau donc
bon bien et mal entraîne beaucoup de
notions avec eux c'est difficile de les
penser de manière absolue déjà parce
qu'ils se définissent en partie déjà un
truc tu vois alors ça c'est la
définition de bien sur internet ensuite
parce que suivant un point de vue une
même chose peut être bien ou mal genre
par exemple les livres physiques les
libraires et écologistes n'auront pas
les mêmes quand la vente des lipides
arrêté après tu as aussi certaines
actions qui peuvent être faites avec une
bonne intention et débouché sur un
résultat mauvais donc bref le mal il
bien de manière absolue pour moi ça
n'existe pas et ça c'est une pensée plus
tôt à thé parce qu'un croyant il a de
grandes chances de dire que si ça existe
et que c'est dieu le bien absolu berges
je précise qu'à chaque fois je vous
donnerai grosso modo montrent que
j'essaierai de nuancer au maximum mais
je peux pas offert tous les points de
vue sur une question juste pas possible
donc ce qui est bien est ce les malades
sont fonction de subjectif
tu te prends ce parti au temps où on tue
les les mal formés et que tu demandes à
un mec de l'époque
si c'est mal il ya beaucoup de chances
qu'ils te disent que c'est pas mal
il te dira que c'est la règle qu'il est
pour aux comptes et pas que c'est mal de
tuer des bébés malformés en fait ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que tu es
par exemple n'est pas absolument mal
avec un l majuscule c'est très chaud de
le comprendre pour nous tellement
l'inversé entrer dans votre esprit on
voit comme tels parce qu'on a grandi
dans un call avec une morale une éthique
dans un pays en plus qui a aboli la
peine de mort au passage la dernière
exécution la guillotine ce temps
1977 où je crois donc c'était même il me
semble après la date de sortie du
premier s'invente pas des pointes
mais si tu regardes les animaux qui
s'entretuent c'est ni mal ni bien bien
et mal ça n'a pas de sens dans la nature
tous les concepts qui sont pointés par
l'homme alors après bien sûr c'est bon
ou mauvais par rapport à l'éthique par
rapport à une morale mais c'est pas bien
mal en soi avec un b m majuscule
voilà j'espère que c'est c'est un
parcours on pourrait parler de ce qui
est bien pour de ce que peut représenter
le bien pour chaque philosophe jean
parlant platon c'est un idéal auquel on
doit se rapprocher pour aristote c'est
le développement maximal pour chats 4 de
sa nature propre pour laisser curien les
épicuriens pardon ça va être le bonheur
voilà c'est en gros pour pour tout dire
pourquoi at elle eu mal à définir ces
notions c'est tout simplement parce que
c'est une notion qui se définissent pas
tout seul voilà j'espère que c'est ça
répond à des questions et que c'est plus
clair pour toi autre question de stephen
fry qu une liberté est-elle réellement
liberté selon lui fixe des limites à lui
à une question qui se pose est ce qu'il
ya des libertés sans limite non je pense
pas peut-être que quoi que tu fasses tes
limites et par quelque chose même si tu
es tout seul dans la société
tm limite est déjà partout environnement
ensuite par les lois de la physique
ensuite parfois même genre est le surmoi
par exemple reflet des tonnes de limite
la liberté
donc oui puisqu'on est l'artère s'est
toujours dit
maintenant la question c'est à partir de
quand ses limites deviennent assez forte
pour qu'on ne puisse plus parler de
lille ta question elle pose l'étude de
cette échelle des limites mais pas que
par exemple un mec ans de prison bah il
n'est pas libre parce qu'il faut pas
aller oui peu mais peut toujours dire ce
qu'il ce qu'ils pensent et peuvent être
oubliés toujours libre de penser ce
qu'il veut donc ça détourne de quelle
liberté on parle aussi alors j'essayais
trouver une classification des libertés
mais j'ai pas trouvé grand chose donc
voilà si quelqu'un a des infos là dessus
qu'ils n'hésitent pas à lâcher un
commentaire ou envoyer un tweet après on
pourrait dire que la liberté c'est toi
faire ce qu'on veut et dans ce cas rien
ne dit que le mec en prison ne veut pas
rester dans sa cellule et donc au final
il fait ce qu'il veut et donc qu'il est
dans un très bon jeu par acheter de la
subjectivité à ta question
sinon on ne s'en sort plus et voilà en
gros si je devais répondre hyper
simplement je dirais que je pense que
oui une liberté réellement une liberté
sont le fixe des limites puisque la
liberté absolue n'existe pas pour nous
pauvres humains que nous sommes et je
t'envoie la dernière vidéo de minutes
papillon sur la liberté qui est
excellente que je la mets dans dans la
description et j'espère que c'est
maintenant plus clair pour toi voilà
c'est tout c'est tout pour pour ce
premier épisode
j'espère que ça vous a plu moi ça m'a
plu si vous voulez poser une question
n'hésitez pas il suffit d'aller sur le
poste de cette vidéo sur la page
facebook en tête donc le lien la page
facebook c'est dans la description et le
prochain ask sera il y aurait un live
band tiendrai informés sur facebook et
twitter
et comment ça va se passer vous invoquez
actuellement je n'ai aucune idée de
comment ça se passe et absolument aucune
idée quand j'ai absolument c'est
absolument pas subjectivement
relativement voilà j'espère que ça vous
a plu
je vous envoie du love et réalise ciao
bye